la poterie j'aimerais trop faire une
vidéo activités manuelles avec de la
poterie avec ce truc là je joue pas
c'est chaud j'avais hâte de trouver
cette vidéo j'avais notamment à dadaab
one on a fait de la poterie
nous avons créé non pas celui qui est
beau et mignon non celui qui est
dégueulasse ah ouais c'est surtout
malgré d'ailleurs qui a rattrapé ce que
j'avais fait qu'ils étaient encore plus
dégueulasse et m'a écouté aujourd'hui on
va se remettre les mains dans l'argile
après avoir fait trembler le domino game
on va faire trembler le poteau égal
alors j'avoue mecque le poterie games et
genre vraiment des artistes vraiment des
gens trop fort qui savent trop bien
utiliser leur main pas comme nous venons
l'utilisent pour cliquer goûter la panne
aux bouffes tout ils l'utilisent pour
fabriquer de très beaux objets bon on
commence par une mise en bouche comme
d'habitude
est-ce que vous avez déjà check et des
vidéos de poterie ou pas n'ont pas
regardé c'est la chose la plus
satisfaisante
après les vidéos domino faut pas
déconner c'est parti c'est très très
très très satisfaisant c'est abusé comme
c'est satisfaisant
regardez c'est trop bien regarder ça
c'est beau mais vous montez la [ __ ]
c'est tellement beau c'est vraiment
absorbant je suis vraiment ébahis devant
de la poterie en fait c'est un peu comme
d'habitude à chaque fois il ya une
discipline qui peut paraître un peu pas
trop intérêt sont tous nuls ou je sais
pas quoi et c'est parce que tu en as
fait en cm2 étaient restés bloqués sur
taux d'opinions est en fait un haut
niveau c'est hyper impressionnant c'est
comme les dominos comme tous les trucs
manuel en fait tous les manuels à un
level très haut c'est super beau avoir
bon après là je vous mets des vidéos qui
sont genre pour les mecs sont trop forts
quoi c'est rarement des artistes
regarder derrière il a plein de vases
étouffe un serment des mecs trop trop
fort ce qui est mon cas nous aussi on va
faire des bases comme un bond cher et où
j'ai un peu honte mais je demande c'est
pas plus est souvent que les dominés par
drew là j'ai peut-être fait vibrer le
coeur de certains l'année quand même bon
bref laissez moi vous présenter quelque
chose
[Musique]
elle bouge alou oui voici s'appelle
comment une roue de poterie électrique
et ouais mon pote g de l'argile naturel
auto durcissant justice y ait écouté
notre objectif est très simple ça va
être juste de faire un bol ça vous
paraît s'arme de faire un bol ça ne
l'est pas du tout déjà juste cet
instrument à lui seul c'est un peu un
rêve d'enfant à l'époque quand j'en
avais fait j'avais celui-ci du coup tu
dois mettre des petits coups d'élan mais
ta main il sauf que ça ralentit avec le
frottement était en galère mais ça s'est
fini c'est comme pour les to on a les
instruments des adultes maintenant parce
qu'on est des adultes plus ou moins
bref ce que ça tombe juste cette plaque
qui tourne et plus divertissante que
l'intégralité de ma chaîne youtube
c'est génial pendant vos laissez moi
vous présenter marque du caisse noire
c'est le pote du poterie game français
ok c'est l'élite de l'élite on y va on
écoute on boit ses paroles et on essaie
surtout de ne pas décevoir marx et
l'important dans cette vidéo
le tournage est sympa pour des jeux wolf
la fillette alors qu'elle considère
gilles faut mettre marque ça dépend la
taille du bol que tu veux faire lucas ok
ok ok merci marc et maintenant 21
personnes dans ma tête depuis début
juillet le cas jugé uniquement dans ta
tête n'existe pas ok et à la fin il a
envoyé comme si c'était un 3-points
basket gros bon bah on retourne à l'état
pur
alors c'est hyper important de santé
parce que comme on utilise la force
centrifuge
il faut vraiment que ce soit au milieu
milieu et encore on va devoir leur
centre est même sûr mais bien au milieu
dès le début
ok la suite marc à doit ensuite je
mouille un peu la terre et mes mains par
la même occasion le centrage de la balle
d'argile sur le tour est essentiel c'est
l'opération la plus importante pour le
tournage et obtenir des volumes d'une
épaisseur constante mais surtout pour
monter les formes sans difficulté marc
tu es le meilleur
alors je mouille les mâts et s'il faut
maintenant le faire tourner
[Musique]
attendez hockey ont tout du début est ce
parce qu'à une étape que j'affectionne
particulièrement où ils ne bougent plus
à l'ope par le centrage de la belle
d'argile sur le tour est essentielle
pour mon téléphone sans difficulté non
non non non mais c'est mon argile qui
est de mauvaise qualité en fait c'est
comme les ballons adhère voix c'est pas
parce que je suis mauvais c'est mon
argile quelle mauvaise qualité
je veux ouvrir un autre truc d'argile il
faut tout nettoyer reprendre le début ça
n'a aucun sens ça commence à me dire il
s'est passé un truc là matt regard
habarcq j'ai du 6 mai ok donc là on a
fait monter comment il a fait
redescendre je monte donc la terre formé
une colonne que je montre puis
redescente plusieurs fois wall à manille
pour la faire redescendre mais on va
essayer moi je vais faire des 100
marques j'ai compris c'est une sensation
extraordinaire chemin pas vous décrire
ce qui se passe vous allez me voir
souvent me mouiller les mains c'est bien
plus pour enlever la thermale que pour
mouiller la terre moi aussi dans cette
marche fait pareil
un petit peu la terre ensuite je vais la
btrc ouah ouah je suis jamais y arriver
[Musique]
au hockey ce que je peux ensuite
oh la vache l'étape de la montée elle
est extraordinaire donc là le but c'est
que je met un doigt comme ça une main
comme ça et que j'écarte petit à petit
comme ça vers l'extérieur pour que ça
fasse la forme mais là c'est ce qui a
l'air un peu technique qu'est ce qui va
arriver je peux rattraper je peux
rattraper ça ceux des calottes voilà on
y est on sait pas au point l'étape
d'avant spa grande panique et pas même
chez était presque [ __ ] j'ai bien mis
un peu d'eau allez on y retourne c'est
parti en fait c'est très compliqué pour
moi mais c'est l'étape la plus
importante et la plus difficile à ils
étaient dans tous les tutorats c'est le
moment où tu dois la centrer quoi
[Musique]
je suis désolé c'est que j'ai aucune
expérience et je suis pas légitime mais
j'ai voulu tenter mais [ __ ] mais vous
êtes trop ya même pas une once de base
dans ce que je fais a été belle j'ajuste
on n'en parle pas il ya un petit lebel
qui a été pris ou pas j'ai l'impression
quand même maintenant c'est le moment du
trou ok et là c'est la [ __ ] d'étape
décisive de la mort la race et semoule
alors ça c'est très dur ça je mettrai ça
y est je suis bloqué j'arrive pas à
l'élargir
moi j'ai la forme inverse de lui malgré
vos vraiment mais mais là je ne sais
plus quoi en fait pour être patient
concentré et pointilleux quand tu as des
qualités que je n'ai jamais
j'ai plus qu'à écrire quelques trucs
dessus je vais le signer avec mon nom
d'artiste
ok c'est fait comment détachées [ __ ]
de truc
et voilà magnifique je peux pas trop
vous le montrez je suis en train de le
déformer mais voilà j'ai fait un verre
ou se mettent à assécher ici bon les
amis n'y a plus que vous et moi et ce
gros pack et d'argile je veux faire un
vase
le ver là c'est pourri ça à côté on va
faire un vase mais et j'aimerais qu'on
en fasse ça qu'on met dans ce décor et
qu'on mette une fleur de dans une plante
bon là ça me ferait vraiment plaisir
je prescris j'avais bien besoin dans
touchant cette boule devait décoller du
siège tellement elle est emportée avec
elle
[Musique]
hu a rigolé en rigolait bien fort je
vous entends bombe à l'estec on commence
à la levée mais qu on arrive à faire des
choses fabuleuses
allez maintenant on descend ça s'est un
peu plus relou
[Musique]
eh ben on est bien loin du résultat
attendu langue ça je vous le fais pas
dire
devenu autonome pendant un instant
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
un mec je veux tellement y arriver si on
n'y arrive vraiment je suis tellement
fier c'est le mans dutroux lettre
vaches en train de donner une forme aux
obliques au vase meyers qui penche d'un
côté que sa valeur double ead et je vous
fais ton inventée que vous puissiez voir
il est une fois en moyenne c'est pas
juste genre un vase droit il a une forme
un peu asymétrique parce qu'en fait dans
la déco d'intérieur puisque les gens
aiment scellé c'est la symétrie
donc là on a la forme finale de la base
qui est vraiment correct maintenant on
va passer aux petits motifs à l'aide
d'une technique qui est très peu répandu
la poterie mais qui pourtant a son
importance c'est à dire appuyer
légèrement sur l'objet pendant que ça
tourne et le vase est là maintenant
extraction du gaz bâtons et de jets bah
non il est roué
bon mec c'est déprimant mais plus ça va
et moins je suis bon dans ces vidéos
car je me sens bien là c'était hier la
cité conneries maintenant c'est fini
alors ça c'est enzo un mini ficus c'est
ce qu'on va planter dans notre
magnifique vase je n'ai pas menti quand
je vous dit qu'on allait faire une
plante et qu'on est là mais dans le
décor c'est vrai bref prenons des news
de notre culture qui ont eu le temps de
sécher on va commencer par le vert voilà
on a notre magnifique vert j'ai bien
travaillé quand même il ya j'avais pas
souvenir d'avoir fait un truc déjà
acquis qui se pose c'est déjà une bonne
étape il sera digne de ce nom si je peux
boire devant ces partis test de l'eau
test réussi
sachez qu'il ya ma douche a duré trois
fois plus longtemps que d'habitude si
j'avais de la terre coincée par tout son
corps sur l'avant bras sous les ongles
dans le nez dans tous les orifices
prénoms des news de notre ami le vase
c'est pas bien sec mais mon petit pote
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'on a
réussi à faire un vase
alors attend peut-être que je parle un
peu vite ah bah écoutez j'ai
l'impression que la mission a été quand
même partiellement réussi j'ai pu faire
un verre qui est utilisable son design
c'est une autre histoire mais il est
utilisable et impôts de plantes
utilisable lui aussi écouté je suis très
heureux d'avoir osé faire cette vidéo
poterie c'est clairement la plus
calamiteuse de toutes les vidéos manuel
qu'on ait fait pendant ça m'a rendu fou
il ya en rentrant gt j'étais vraiment
triste face à ma prestation nul mais
vraiment quoi je pensais vraiment que
j'allais réussir à faire mieux j'ai
vraiment sous-estimé bas comme souvent
en fait quand je lance dans une activité
manuelle
j'espère que ça vous a plu et en
attendant je prends mes petits copains
pierre et titouan et je m'en vais a très
vite
[Musique]
à